- [Instructor] Though they
seem like an unusual way
to extinguish a fire, engineering students
are designing low frequency
sound wave devices
to put out flames.
All right that was really strange
because they're saying though they seem
like an unusual way to extinguish a fire.
So they're referring to they
as something that's an unusual way
to extinguish a fire.
And then right after that
they say engineering students
so they're implying that
the engineering students
are the they.
So let me put a little.
The way the sentence is constructed
it makes it sound like
engineering students
are the they, that engineering students
are an unusual way to extinguish a fire
and that would be an unusual way indeed.
But what they're really trying to say is
that low frequency sound wave devices,
that low frequency sound wave devices
are the unusual way to extinguish a fire.
So I would like the second
clause to start with
low frequency sound wave devices.
So let's look at the choices.
So I definitely don't like it as is.
So though they seem like an unusual way
to extinguish a fire, engineering students
so they're doing that same thing again.
Though they seem like an unusual way
to extinguish a fire, low
frequency sound wave devices,
okay I'm liking this so far
because it's clear that the they
is referring to low
frequency sound wave devices
designed by engineering students
are being used to put out flames.
So I'm liking this choice right over here.
So let's look at this last one,
though they seem like an unusual way
to extinguish a fire, flames are,
and so this is implying
that flames is the they.
And so you can just
replace they with flames
and see if that makes sense.
Though flames seem like an unusual way
to extinguish a fire,
once again that would be an unusual way.
That's not even what they wanna say.
They wanna say that the
low frequency sound waves,
that's the they, so I
don't like this one either.
So I'm definitely liking that choice.